[Musique]
robert aime le karaté il pense que son
fils félix va aimer ça aussi il inscrit
un cours aux services de loisirs de sa
ville
mais quelques jours avant le premier
cours fedex lui annonce qu'il ne veut
rien savoir du karaté pote problème dit
robert
la loi prévoit qu'on pu résilier ce
genre de contrat à tout moment mais
surprise la ville refuse
pourquoi parce que les services de
loisirs municipaux ne sont pas visées
par la loi sur la protection du
consommateur
toutefois sachez que dans les cas où une
entreprise privée louer une salle à la
ville pour donner des cours la loi
s'applique
cela dit certaines villes se fondre un
point d'honneur de rembourser leurs
citoyens mais pas celle de robert le fin
mot de l'histoire
mieux vaut connaître votre partenaire ah
oui devient votre adversaire